oh
mon Dieu
quelque chose les a ramenés
la portée sur le sol est assez
instable
j'ai quelqu'un qui a un talent spécial
pour ce genre de choses nous les appelons
l'alpha comme un chien pas
comme un loup
si tu peux guérir tu pourrais jouer demain
soir  tu pourrais
commencer à être prêt à apprendre annuler mes
deux heures je dois tenir mes appels
vas-tu être en réunion ouais genre de
elle est là
[Musique]
trop genre de sentiment que les réponses sont à
Beacon Hills  il y a
longtemps
[Musique]
comment savons-nous qu'elle est vraiment Alice qui
es-tu
c'est Dieu
qui
qui que ce soit ou quoi que ce soit là-bas en ce
moment
ce n'est pas Allison
nous avons besoin de tout le monde
il se passe plus et je pense que
tout va
bien
alors les aides de cuisine viennent  pour jouer à un nouveau
jeu,
aidez-la à se rappeler qui elle était
en train de transférer, c'est comme s'il
faisait tomber des pièces du plateau, alors comment se fait-il qu'il m'ait remis dessus
un loup fait mais il va mourir